immer mehr auto attacken auf juweliere
geklaute caro und ab damit durch die
fensterscheibe eines schmuckgeschäfts
mit dieser brutalo masche öffnen sich
diese immer öfter typen zu diamanten
uhren und goldschmuck und haben neue
erschreckende überfall bilder einer
überwachungskamera
erreicht
und fast jede nacht kommt es bei uns zu
einbrüchen in geschäften ganz besonders
im visier der verbrecher juweliere dabei
nutzen die gangster immer öfter
gestohlene fahrzeuge um sich so zutritt
zu verschaffen das auto als rammbock
quasi in nordrhein westfalen haben diebe
mit dieser brutale masche jetzt erneut
zugeschlagen
bianca weiner und lily von der osten
berichten
tatort moers in nordrhein westfalen mit
vollgas brettern die verbrecher durch
die eingangstür roms einbruch beim
juwelier am frühen mittwochmorgen gegen
350 hatten anwohner einen lauten knall
schaute aus dem fenster und sahen wie
bei diesem juwelier im eingang einen
dunkelgrünen mitsubishi stecken kurz
darauf flüchtete auch schon ein dunkler
bmw hier die fußgängerzone entlang die
einzige spur zu den verbrechern ist der
pkw eingeklemmt zwischen glas metall und
mauern das auto gestohlen das
nummernschild gefälscht nicht die
einzige miese masche der gangster um
ankommende polizeiautos bei der
verfolgung zu hindern verteilen die
verbrecher nagelbretter kreuz und quer
in der straße ja für uns ungewöhnlich
war tatsächlich dass die täter über die
komplette breite der fußgängerzonen
nagelbretter ausgelegt hatten offenbar
um eine verfolgung durch die polizei zu
erschweren ein streifenwagen ist dann
auch prompt über dieses nagel wird
drüber gefahren oder über eins dieser
nagelbretter drüber gefahren und wurde
auch stark beschädigt
das ist nicht der einzige ort in dem
dreister juwelen diebe auf diese weise
zu schlagen besonders das benutzen eines
autos als rammbock es deutschlandweit
bei den gangstern sehr beliebt in den
letzten zwölf monaten kommt es zu
zahlreichen solcher ums einbrüchen 20
tage vor dem bruch in börßum nur knapp
20 kilometer weiter essen borbeck die
dunkelheit bricht herein dreiste blitz
einbrecher schlagen zu niederbrechen
gangster bei einem juwelier in der
innenstadt ein wieder zerstören sie die
eingangstür mit einem gestohlenen
fahrzeug am 19 januar gegen 20 uhr gab
es hier im hintergrund bei diesem
juwelier einen blitzeinbruch die täter
haben an einem ford focus eine metallene
ramme vorne angebracht und sind mit
dieser ramme dann durch die gläserne
eingangstür gefahren zeugen sehen
mehrere männer mit gefüllten taschen aus
dem juweliergeschäft flüchten fette
beute mit einem grauen ford entkommen
sie unerkannt in die essener dunkelheit
hannover frühjahr 2021 im rückwärtsgang
dieser gestohlene mazda in die
eingangstür eines juweliers in der
kröpcke passage die ganoven zerstören
alle vitrinen stopfen ihre taschen voll
und flüchten drei gangster zwei minuten
und eine sechsstellige beute
leipzig zwei monate später der millionen
coup mit vollgas dieser geklautes cola
durch eine shopping passage und brettert
gegen das rolltor eines luxus juweliers
scherben splitter der bruch beginnt
keine vitrine keine ablage ist sicher
vor den gierigen gangstern mehr als 100
uhren und schmuckstücke im wert von
einer million euro reißen sie an sich
hinterlassen einen schaden am geschäft
von knapp 100000 euro mit ihrem
diebesgut flüchten sie weiter in einem
gestohlenen pkw durch die passage
[Musik]
razzia in polen drei tage nach dem
leipziger million beschlagnahmen
polizisten uhren schmuck und bargeld im
wert von mehreren hunderttausend euro
teile der sichergestellten beute sind
unter anderem die bis güter aus hannover
und leipzig von den gangstern über die
grenze nach polen gebracht und beim
illegalen verkauf von der polizei
erwischt fünf männer werden festgenommen
die wertgegenstände an ihre rechtmäßigen
eigentümer zurückgegeben
[Applaus]
zwei verhandlungserfolge doch als julia
lebt man weiterhin gefährlich in
deutschland achter februar 17 und 40
kurfürstendamm in berlin der nächste
überfall auf einen luxus uhren geschäft
während andere leute shoppen gehen
brechen drei männer bei hublot hinter
mir ein einer der täter klingelte an der
tür
die 30 jährige verkäuferin öffnet ihm
diese und der täter zog unmittelbar
seine waffe und kommt so eine luxus
laden rein seine zwei komplizen folgen
ihm und stehen dutzende uhren binnen
weniger minuten sind sie wieder da raus
und richten ein schaden von mehreren
hunderttausend euro an
das räuberische trio flüchtete in einem
silbernen pkw vom tatort die
spurensicherung zieht sich bis in die
späten abendstunden
essen berlin leipzig hannover nur einige
beispiele denn märz gibt der chor der
unbekannten gangster nicht auf sondern
endet im eingang der inhaber des
juweliers ist vorbereitet die vom
geschäftsinhaber installierte
sicherheitstechnik hat dann dazu geführt
dass der pkw sich dann total verkatert
in diesem eingangsbereich und die täter
gar nicht mehr aus dem fahrzeug heraus
kam
die gescheiterten blitz einbrecher
entkommen durch den kofferraum ohne
beute flüchten sie aus der sonst so
friedlichen moerser innenstadt in einem
schwarzen fahrzeug die fahndung läuft
wenn sie also etwas zu einem dieser
fälle wissen hinweise nimmt jede
polizeidienststelle entgegen